none of us can or should expect a
transformation in race relations
overnight every time something like this
happens somebody says we we have to have
a conversation about race we talk a lot
about race there's no shortcut we don't
need more top
nine of us should believe that a handful
of gun safety measures will prevent
every tragedy it will not people of
goodwill will continue to debate the
merits and various policies as our
democracy requires is a big raucous
place America is and they're good people
on both sides of these debates whatever
solutions we find will necessarily be
incomplete but it would be a betrayal of
everything Reverend pickney stood for I
believe if we allowed ourselves to slip
into a comfortable silence again right
once the eulogies have been delivered
once the TV cameras move on to go back
to business as usual right
that's what we so often do to avoid
uncomfortable truths about the prejudice
that still infects our society to settle
for symbolic gestures without following
up with the hard work of more lasting
change that's how we lose our way again
it would be a refutation of the
forgiveness expressed by those families
if we merely slipped into old habits
whereby those who disagree with us are
not merely wrong but ban where we shout
instead of listen where we barricade
ourselves behind preconceived notions or
well practiced cynicism